this is a mess none of these storylines
make any sense what whoa
just working for you oh no I hey what do
you what are you doing
I mean of course they would do this I
love this I love this so we're going to
I am Groot
okay
with you there
oh shoot wow she's on the Sound Stage
this is so trippy I love the idea this
episode is so good
do you see where the Disney line is over
there check it left what I genuinely
they could make easily a spin-off of her
choosing different shows to jump into
and I would say right I know I would
just watch that as the intro to every
that should be the opening fan yeah
we're just kicking open stuff like
remember the Lilo and Stitch uh promos
how uh Lilo or just Stitch would show up
in The Lion King and Aladdin and Beauty
and the Beast that's what I want for
She-Hulk
Kevin it stands for knowledge oh my god
he has a hat
he's got a little hat why is
do you think this is what um very
expensive people Round Up Marvel's
offices say to Kevin feige like is off
you you're not a face you're a robot I
feel like Kevin feige chose this I think
he chose this for himself man what kind
of drums there that was fun
cousin Bruce
[Music]
I love him in casual clothes I can never
get over it I have someone here that I'd
like you all to meet
he didn't have a dad teach him how to
cut his hair yet wow my dad never taught
me how to go by Harry this took me to
Supercuts
the car they don't have a damn Super
Cuts on cigar yo that never mind
that dude has my hairline that thing is
like why are y'all coming you know teens
are so impressionable and so insecure
and you two are coming for him
I didn't say anything about the actor
the actor's great I'm talking about it
because he's a kid and that's just his
hair
the guy behind the VFX I'm saying the
characters
listen we also have to consider that uh
cigars uh only Barbara is an old man
with that looks like Stan Lee so uh you
guys are going to get it right okay
that's right empty you're right you're
right
a child maybe cut his hairline okay and
Jess you also get a rogie you both get
Rogue you're right y'all were coming for
him so bad
oh my God and clearly you see where his
hairline is it just is cutting back here
right I know I know yeah it just reminds
me of a couple tick tocks where they're
like what did you do what did you do you
start shaving his eyebrows off
welcome back to New rockstars the
She-Hulk finale She-Hulk smashed Down
the Walls of reality in the MCU
revealing the whole MCU is the work of
an AI robot hidden on Disney's Burbank
lot named Kevin we thought Tatiana
maslani was Emmy worthy for her
character work at Orphan Black but give
this robot an Emmy for his Kevin feige
impression holy [ __ ]
[Music]
this is inside Marvel new rock stars
She-Hulk after show I'm Eric Voss with
me it's Jessica Clemens nmt welcome
friends we made it yeah we did make it
I'm so tired that I'm I just want to
clarify this because someone's gonna be
like she's drinking pee I'm drinking a
Red Bull I'm drinking a rabbit but
someone is gonna be me why are you
drinking it Jessica stop I said it was
you know I'm gonna clarify this
and then I also have a Gatorade because
I keep my fluids gotta keep my fluids
wow okay so you're drinking this to
clarify this is not an iced coffee this
is this is that is pink oh that is poopy
sorry
it's Burpy
um a bit nutty
we are starting off strongly it's early
we finally made it to the end
we did and uh what I mean look there's a
lot of mixed opinions about this finale
I think the overall consensus is
positive because what a big swing what a
what a fascinating way in my opinion to
totally stick the landing on this show I
think all the only thing I wanted more
from this finale is to just introduce
some of these meta elements sooner like
yes she broke the fourth wall throughout
the show the fact that she could like in
the first episode skip ahead to the
flashback that was going to be later in
the series and then jump back and kind
of call the shots from within the scene
is one thing but like remember in one
division how like in episode three like
literally things got rewound on camera
or there's like a glitch I would have
loved more glitches throughout the show
just to kind of set up that this was all
being president of the Mind of a robot I
think would have been would have set it
up but I mean it's a Twist that I just
totally blew me away left a lot of
unanswered questions but to me I don't I
can let go of those things I I was just
really happy with this I liked it
sorry I liked it but I think I had a
little quarrels with it but I think a
lot of my Coral was like I I was one of
the people that from the jump was like I
don't think we're gonna see a son I
don't think we're gonna see his son
because I would take away a lot of
storyline from She-Hulk and they've made
it very apparent that this is a She-Hulk
show and I think even when they broke
the fourth wall with Kevin she was still
leaning like oh we'll just get into it
in the movie and Kevin still placed it
in their last minute and was like here's
the Sun and I was like not in a mean way
but I was like okay I want to know more
about this than I do about any of the
rest of this episode if that makes sense
because I was like it did take a lot of
my attention bringing him back with his
son I was like this is a big deal what
do you mean we're gonna get into it
later how are we gonna even like oh are
we gonna open on the barbecue in his
movie in six years
yeah I think Jesse was saying before we
started rolling that that might have
been a better post-credits scene uh than
we got and I agree I would have liked If
This Were detached from the rest of the
episode I would have it definitely would
have been like a fun post credit scene
for me I agree I'm just gonna say like I
I also am a little bit mixed on this
ending like I really enjoyed the fourth
wall break I I'm a huge sucker for uh a
fourth wall break but I just feel like
you know the entire series like all the
you know like the whole blood storyline
and like I kind of wanted more from that
and like you know I just I think that
like I like how things were just
jokingly sort of just like wrapped up
like yeah you know what because it makes
my show I'm just ending this the way I
want you I think that's fun but like I
kind of wish those pay off to like you
know the Titania stuff like why did she
attack the courtroom
um in the first episode we never got um
an explanation for that well um okay
I've been getting called out about it so
I guess it was a dress but I still do
not believe this and I don't think we
should as a unit we shouldn't believe it
we shouldn't believe it so yeah they
said the low blood sugar but it said she
was on her way it was like a shortcut to
traffic court that she busted through
there and I'm still like that's not a
good justification that's not a good job
I don't think we were meant to take that
seriously for face value I think that
was just her cover story yeah I think
that was her statement that's what I
said I keep getting called out people
like they didn't say it I'm like I don't
believe it though well I think uh it's
it's hard uh well first off you'll never
win an argument with people on social
media what do you mean I think a lot of
times I think a lot of us
you just have to be able to like go all
the way all uh all 12 rounds and then
and then you'll win
um no I think a lot of people will watch
these shows and maybe this is our fault
as well because we watch these shows
this way looking for specific evidence
to to fix it and to plug the plot hole
but if it's not like overt and clearly
like uh only
emotionally
honest with the way the character like
is being presented and and verified by
external sources within the context of
the plot and the story then like if yeah
if it's not obvious to you as you're
watching the story then yeah I don't
know if like we could say that that was
clearly explained and Justified like I
think she was set up to be a mystery
character that we would find out more
about later and we never did
yeah that's that's a little bit of a
bummer for me but like you know overall
like I really dug how Jen took control
of her reality and like I sort of sort
of makes you feel like you know Jennifer
Walters is the strongest being in the
MCU like Universe because it's just like
she altered reality some ways to such a
huge degree that it's just like man like
Wanda maximoff who at this point like
holy [ __ ] well yeah to Jess's point if
scar does end up showing up anyway in
that final scene how strong is she
because it does sound like it is the
Kevin robot show it still doesn't plug
scar back and it kind of
not like denounce but like art like
conflicts with the whole like her entire
Spiel of being like this is my show my
Stakes what happened to me I need to
like I think we don't need to do this
gaudy stuff we don't need to do these
reveals when it's about me and what
happened to me and I overcome those and
I was like yeah I agree with that I was
like I completely agree with that and
then it's still thrown in there and I'm
like
I don't know maybe I was just like I
took scar really far I love it I love
the idea of Hulk having a son and I
really did want to get into Santa's car
but I just wanted it like post-credit or
not at all because I don't want it to
take away oh like we're going to be
talking about this more than we're gonna
be talking about
her overcoming her con her own inner
struggles yeah I think you're right um I
I think we are all on board with score
existing oh Darla has opinions I get it
I feel it it's my dog you'll see it
you'll see a shadow of a dog back here
um no I think uh you're totally right
um and I think in terms of like
revealing new characters in the MCU just
kind of quietly standing perfectly
behind your dad Bruce in the backyard of
an LA home is not the most exciting way
to introduce a character he doesn't get
to say anything he's just like um
also I talked about this in the first
breakdown or second breakdown I think
when we introduced our family we learned
that that woman is Rebecca uh Rebecca
Banner who could potentially be Bruce's
mom and I don't think they named the
aunt Rebecca and not on purpose to be
like this could be Bruce's mom from the
comics they there's a million names they
could have chosen from so I'm like
Rebecca did not react at all to that
being her grandson if that is her
grandson so I was I just uh it's okay
it's okay I don't mean to go off about
it yeah we're um look this this whole
show was kind of a Fiddler on the Roof
son might say it was walking uh Razor's
Edge in terms of its balance with the
meta elements in the in-universe
storytelling and it's a very very tricky
thing to do you have to really uh know
your audience extremely well to be able
to know when to be sincere and which uh
actual plot points you want the audience
to care about and to worry about and to
feel anxiety for and to want payoff for
uh and which things they can like let go
of and I think um there just might have
been like having uh the ending of one
episode showing us a big scary needle I
think was just maybe a step too far if
just the blood plot was something in the
background that was rarely addressed and
then just kind of introduced like a
random thing in that episode I think we
all would have been like yeah what but
they they clearly developed like wants
us to be invested in that uh blood theft
storyline so you have to you have to be
careful but I think like I don't know
your mileage may vary I think
introducing the Kevin robot with the hat
so like everything that robot said was
like a few steps ahead of the audience
and I was very very impressed with how
well in my opinion Marvel Studios seemed
to understand the criticisms toward
phase four with this robot and was able
to use it to address a lot of it I
thought that was just delightful I think
it's great but that's just me still
through and Scar that's the thing I was
like he listened to her he listened to
her and then was like well I'm still
gonna add this bit because I know the
show and it's my show and I was like
okay I get that you're Kevin feige or
sorry Kevin Kevin Kevin
um we're going to talk about exactly
what this robot is uh and for those of
you who are saying wait you're saying
things that are not like 100 positive
this is our job we are just reacting to
this stuff the morning after and our
feelings are always a bit mixed this is
what inside Marvel is for it's for the
three of us to be able to like just kind
of pick each other's brains and react
honestly to this stuff most of the time
we're positive about this stuff because
we do genuinely feel positive about the
stuff we know how hard it is to make
this stuff but generally if you watch
the finale after show on inside Marvel
go back and watch the one after Hawkeye
the one after Ms Marvel the one after
Loki the one after popular Winter
Soldier the one after one Division and
yeah you'll see a lot of mixed feelings
but it doesn't mean like obviously all
three of us genuinely uh like support
everything that's happening here and we
care enough about it to go into the
details and try to figure out what
worked and what didn't uh and just go
with us on this journey don't come after
us on Twitter saying why were you hating
on it yes there are other accounts on on
YouTube that do just generally
I go in on She-Hulk because I love
She-Hulk it is out of a matter of I read
every damn comic and I'm gonna go off
about
all right let's uh recap what happened
so the finale opens with a shopper shot
parody of the intro um for the 1978 Bill
Bixby Incredible Hulk TV series finally
confirming with those hazy shots of Jen
and Bruce in the 70s attire from that
very very first teaser we're all about I
love that I'm so glad so glad that we
came back to that and by the way that
November 2021 teaser also showed Jen
landing on that Burbank Sound Stage so
this meta ending was in the works from
the beginning yes I love that I go into
it but the and they edited the you know
they edit out those little the lights
from The Sound Stage for the trailer so
you would not know it was like oh
they're clearly on a lot but I love it
right right it just kind of looks like a
warehouse like kind of a vacant
Warehouse so this was fun I I love that
I love it so much and uh and it also
reminded us I believe in the 2008 at
Norton Hulk they did bring in like the
shot of him in the chair with the laser
beam on his on his head like already
this stuff was kind of MCU Cannon so for
it to come full circle like that was
really fun but the 70s intro is all a
Dream from Jenna she wakes up in a dodc
prison cell yikes so Jen has to wear an
inhibitor ankle bracelet she loses her
job her home has to move back in with
her parents she and Nikki plan to hunt
down the intelligencia internet trolls
and I just you know I love a good yarn
board oh my God
Mr Chicken no chicken man they're like
these cards I can't wait to see when you
break down from this and and by the way
to everyone watching Jess is going to be
her breakdown is coming out tomorrow on
the channel Jess you've been doing an
amazing yeah
with these breaks so detailed so funny
so entertaining I love everything that
you have done on this season
um so everyone watch that tomorrow it's
gonna be a blast um but um so while
they're hanging out at home uh they find
this old College dancing video of Jen
and Nikki is able to use this posting on
the intelligency website and uh
immediately gets a response from Hulk
King inviting her to this hangout the
median ends up being a bunch of like
men's rights activist types that plug
has to infiltrate with Nikki feeding him
sexy stuff to stay behind it to blend in
and I loved this so much because like
he's like won't people notice me with
one of these and she's like everyone has
it
hang out with these in my ears sometimes
with people whispering sexist stuff for
me to say and the worst things I say is
just because someone's feeding it into
my head that's no man actually believes
these things there's just some toxic
robot who's like Whispering into our
ears these things to say right I think
um anyway this whole uh I just love
anytime pug and uh and yeah I didn't
team up what a pairing iconic Duo it's
wonderful so Abomination is their guest
speaker Jen wanders in uh apparently
this is all going down at this Farm uh
and Blonsky claims that he's just
hosting this for the money and so I was
a little worried I'm like blonski we
just learned you're a good guy but you
know it seems like he's just kind of I
mean blansky you can't you can't claim
innocence here you're hosting them in
your barn you gotta look into their
politics I agree to host people
completely uh like that completely I
know these proud boys or proud boys uh
it's like but I did host them at my
private culti Ranch anyway
um so uh Todd confirms that he used Josh
to steal her blood to develop a serum he
injects himself with it to Hulk out it's
real wacky
[Laughter]
you know James Gunn was watching this
being like
that's my thing
I did it
um wait did James gonna do the second
one no I think we did both of them I
thought am I right okay who's at least a
producer on the second one
um but um so Titania Smashes in I love
Nikki's line does this person ever use a
door she said does this [ __ ] ever use a
door
um Bruce Hulk drops from the ceiling uh
yeah it doesn't make sense and Jen turns
to camera and calls out how none of this
is really lining up the episode takes a
crazy turn Jen punches out of the Disney
plus Marvel Studios home screen swings
from the Loki thumbnail into um the
Marvel assembled documentary which is a
very smart choice because she knows that
we'll take her behind the scenes to the
Disney lot instead of you know some uh
weird TBA location or Tallow or some
other place that's not gonna help her
um so she she passes a crew member I
don't think I saw this like remember's
doing an interview about making The
Infinity Gauntlet yeah
that was really fun
um we follow her walking across the
actual Disney Burbank lot this reminded
me of that Treehouse of Horror Homer uh
thing where he's like 3D Homer walking
in live action world and it was just
kind of like staring over when it's
quiet so he used to scare the crap out
of me as a kid yeah oh it's really
unsettling yeah um and yeah this is the
actual Disney Burbank lot it's less than
a five minute drive from New Rockstar's
Burbank office we drove we drive by it
every day I mean I don't live in LA
anymore but Jess you drive by it every
day on your way to work in fact we we
were probably driving by on Olive when
they were shooting this scene if you
think about it whenever they're shooting
it it was probably a weekday and we were
probably driving by on our way in to
that office anyway I just I love that I
love us being able to claim that we're
part of the MCU in some way and
technically everyone in the world is now
that she jumped into our part of the
Universe
um but she walks into the She-Hulk
writers room uh She-Hulk writers like
Jessica gal cameo in the room
um they uh all the writers blamed this
contrived ending on Kevin and Jen
marches over to the main Marvel Studios
offices she Scrolls through the digital
NDA that all visitors have to sign on
the way in this is a real thing they
have a tablet that you have to I mean
this is what we've been told none of us
have actually been there but like this
is famously what they they make everyone
do she fights through security which is
really fun uh and she breaks into the
Vault
um and there actually is like a closed
off room which is which is kind of like
a military type like you cannot bring in
your phone into this room and it's a
vault and that it's where like they have
dry erase boards and all their plans
like pinned up comic issue pictures
concept art for everything they have
planned uh so it is like a fascinating
thing that it's kind of the new Disney
vaults among like uh Disney conspiracy
theorists uh because they're like what
is in this room who's been in this room
what have you seen when you're in there
and here Jen meets Kevin standing for
knowledge enhanced visual
interconnectivity Nexus who's an AI
robot based on Marvel head Kevin feige
use an algorithm to come up with all MCU
story lines Jen convinces Kevin to
change her Show's ending so that there
there's no Hulk tide no Bruce returning
in the final fight no Abomination and
add Daredevil Jen asks about the X-Men
Kevin gives her no answers there uh she
also brings up the possibility of a Hulk
movie he shoots it down because you know
he was gonna use Hulk to introduce
someone he does anyway uh and Jen says
that she's a Hulk and Hulk smash things
and she smashes fat Indians and
sometimes Matt Murdock which I love that
joke that was fun jyn returns to the
farm and has Todd arrested she meets up
with Daredevil he's literally just
fortnites from the sky uh there were
some was some trees but was Daredevil
just suited up in a tree up in Northern
he was in Disney Heaven Disney heaven
and just got shot also does he just not
know okay I love it we'll get into it
does he just die no I guess she knows
that he got dropped but he's like oh I'm
just not in New York whatever right
um yeah yeah uh poor foggy Nelson was in
the middle of a pastrami sandwich and
just lost the guy who was gonna split
the bill with him
foggy's just holding it down at Nelson
Murdoch by himself it's like where's my
partner and your honor my co-counsel
will be back uh from the sky any moment
um so Blonsky gets returned to custody
seems a little too okay with it and the
episode ends with this fast and furious
style of family Barbecue uh Dom Toretto
is working the grill probably uh
everyone meets Matt grills him about his
lawyer job in Hell's Kitchen uh Bruce
returns and introduces everyone to his
son scar who is a VFX version of actor
Will dusner very exciting for him I
can't wait to see what happens next with
scar whether he's probably he's probably
gonna be in some Hulk movie maybe join
up with the Young Avengers that'd be
really fun this is really big for this
actor uh it's just you know the intro
the way this character was introduced
was just a little silly but I love that
he's in the MCU now and I think it's
really fun I also just love a scene
where like Daredevil meets Hulk
technically even though they don't
really get a moment but like we're in a
c now where Daredevil and Hulk are
talking to each other yeah they're in
the same area yeah in the same area same
general vicinity
um Jen heads back into court striking a
pose matching the closing courtroom art
that we've seen in every closing title
sequence that was fun she decides she's
going to help both people who the law
fails then through the law and then we
get this post credit scene showing Wong
opening a sling ring portal to bailout
Blonsky again and Blonsky says Wong got
sucked into another show referring to
his binge habits or could Wong be
appearing in a new Disney plus series
we'll see there's so much to talk about
in this episode and uh we're gonna start
we need to talk about Kevin I think is
the yes we need to talk about Kevin I
say that earlier why did I say that damn
it yeah you said it now at least you
said it I came up with I improvised it
now why didn't I think of this at 2AM
last night God
you didn't think about home alone I
think you're fine I think you're fine
you're fine
chess we gotta we gotta start over where
we all screamed Kevin
no time no time um now my dog thinks I'm
mad at her she's like why are you
yelling she's like I'm already afraid of
you
all right empty you wouldn't hit the hit
us with that merch plug and guys be sure
to head on over to new
rockstarsmerch.com today to grab our
latest Obsession shirt to Lady Justice
inspired by the She-Hulk attorney at law
series the shirt is limited edition
support the channel and check out all of
our awesome merch options over at
newrockstarsmerch.com today thank you
and Jess you want to hit us with that
question and you can um uh deliver Kevin
however you like
with chicken
did she did The Shield finale break the
MCU
I think it did but is the MCU broken
Beyond repair maybe let's go through
everything we now can um infer from
Kevin's existence because with the
introduction of Kevin this AI robot
using the algorithm to craft all these
storylines the MCU in my opinion it's a
stroke of a little madcap genius that
may go too far but for now seems to be
super fun and for me at least it fixes
not only some of the issues I've had
with the series but also some of the MCU
as of late despite breaking some other
elements within this show now as we know
She-Hulk is a character who breaks the
fourth wall so having her break through
the fourth wall of the Disney plus
platform into Disney's Burbank Studio a
lot to yell at her writer's room and
confront Kevin is very on brand for the
character
um as I said it would have been
interesting to see little teases of this
particular step of the fourth wall
breaking earlier on the show but I'm
glad we went there and I'm actually
really really grateful that Kevin feige
himself did not show up in the vault the
way Lorne Michael sometimes will on SNL
sketches because you know feige is
absolutely a charmer it's a very
entertaining guy in interviews and at uh
in announcements but I think he's
smartly sidelined himself here because I
just I think a cameo from him might have
been a little too indulgent and uh
cringy done in this way I think a lot of
people would have uh that would have
taken us out of it too much so instead I
like that they did this solid parody of
himself as this faceless AI robot who
reads comic books and feeds an algorithm
which is a dig at how all streamers
these days are using algorithmic data to
guide programming decisions uh watch the
most recent season of Barry on HBO for
more on this like coming to the MCU oh
de Patel definitely
like this is a scary thing that like a
lot of programming decisions are just
like being driven by data also it's it's
kind of like a little bit of a um I
wouldn't say a nod but like you know you
know I like Space Jam did the whole
algae rhythm with Don Cheadle yes it's
like yes Disney has a one and it's
freaking Kevin the robot I think it's
hilarious yeah I mean Westworld had this
that's something like all the creators
are now like biting the hand in that
regard it's freaky I like that it's a
robot just because it's I know that uh
in an interview Jessica gal said that
they had to remove a lot of the jokes
making fun of Marvel because it was too
heavy-handed and so I like the idea of
them like the writer's just having what
other than making Kevin feige a God it's
like what else could we make him that's
next to that and I guess it's a very
sentient robot because it's just like
they were they when the writer was like
I would kill you if you come again Kevin
and it's like okay well you guys have a
really bad attachment to this person I'm
like yeah yeah we all do we all very
much have a horrible
and by making him this kind of like
pathetic robot with his tiny little arms
who's moving around it kind of lowers
his status a little bit he's he's stuck
in that room he's literally like chained
to the wall through this through this
arm so it doesn't make him like a god so
much as like a prisoner which I just I
there's so many choices with this robot
that I really just appreciated I think
made it work really well now for years
though many of us have been theorizing
that the MC would introduce Kevin feige
as the metacosmic entity the one above
all and feige you know with his
interviews his announcements his General
Persona they really have been an
inextricable part of the MCU the way
like Walt Disney was an inextricable
Persona to Disney Animation in the 60s
you know he's such an on-camera presence
who's just kind of like in the
background of all this stuff it just
makes sense that um Kevin would be
established somehow in universe and I
think this is a a smartly subversive
satirical approach because feige proves
that he doesn't take himself too
seriously he hears the criticisms uh he
there was that line of like oh oh we
it's too expensive to show your VFX so
can you revert and just do it off camera
okay so you are aware of it great great
I'm glad I'm glad that they did that uh
brings up the X-Men delays the fact that
they force in these cameos just to set
up later movies they're all aware of it
and uh I want to talk briefly about the
design of the Kevin robot
um because I think it's smart that he's
not a super Advanced glowing technology
from like alien Advanced races no he's
just kind of a beat up faceless robot
who wears red and white like he's
cosplaying in the Avengers time travel
suits and end game uh he's got this brim
that looks like heaven feige's signature
ball cap he's got these old school like
lenses he's red blue and green lights
that emit from these knobs of course red
blue green being the base colors of
digital pixels on screen he looks like
he has a USB import drive but not a USBC
just like an old-school USB uh drive and
I it looks like a few disc drives as
well like a like maybe a DVD or a
Blu-ray Drive at the top you don't
really see that on computers anymore so
he's kind of like dated in in like the
early 2000s in some ways and the whole
apparatus is just this bulky orb that's
suspended from the ceiling or Dare we
say chained from the ceiling and he uses
I don't think I saw this two film reels
are spinning on the back of
to me he comes off like a nerdy Cinema
projectionist like the movie nerd who
was like oh I have the keys to the
kingdom let me decide all these things
and the closing credits are shows him
reading a She-Hulk comic book so in my
opinion this is not a soulless evil AI
the way Zola's algorithm is it's like
this guy's pretty funny he's
self-deprecating and his algorithm is
informed by a true love of comics he
listens to feedback for a brief period
though he does just subvert it when Jen
leaves the room
um at the end of the day I think this is
just a bit of delightful bit of
Machinery uh to be the Mind behind the
MCU I'd rather have this robot in the
real world making creative decisions
than most of the studio heads in
Hollywood I'll say that but we should
unpack the implications of it did the
MCU just establish that all MCU titles
from the first Iron Man were actually
made by this AI robot not necessarily
for one in this universe there is still
a She-Hulk writer's room who still had
some authority to make these choices
according to MCU Cannon all MCU titles
are still made by a team of creatives
banging their heads together around a
table but like all Studio Productions
there's always some studio Machinery
behind those creatives secondly this
robot didn't necessarily always exist
it's on the Disney lot so it could just
be a piece of Disney proprietary
technology that wasn't there at the
beginning of the MCU in 2008 that's when
Marvel Studios was an independent Studio
that didn't partner with Disney they
partnered with Paramount and Universal
Universal being like how they partnered
to make the Incredible Hulk film and now
they're able to like get around that it
was maybe this robot was rolled out when
Disney bought out Marvel ahead of Age of
Ultron and Age of Ultron was a story
about the dangers of an AI robot which
would be a pretty appropriate first
story designed by someone like Kevin
truly I think Kevin may be a new piece
of technology introduced after Avengers
in-game to help Marvel Studios keep
track of all their Disney Plus shows and
phase 4 titles which have been as Kevin
admits a mixed bag so this way we can
blame phase Four's unevenness on Kevin
while not giving him credit for the full
Infinity Saga I think this is a pretty
smart bit of commentary on like how thin
Kevin feige has been stretched because
it's specifically the past couple years
on Disney plus and so many minutes of
content that they've had to balance and
keep all interconnected but here's what
I think we should focus on someone had
to build this robot in Universe this
robot didn't build itself someone built
it someone built Ultron someone built
this robot he who remains was the man
behind the curtain who initially hid
behind timekeeper robots so there could
still be an in Universe one above all
who engineered this technology and
perhaps this metapocket reality that Jen
stumbled into so as I opened the forward
for discussion I post to you both of you
the theory since we know the TVA has
film projectors that show MCU history
with the same cinematography the same
storyboarding the same editing as the
directors who shot those movies in real
life the 2012 Avengers the Ragnarok
Avengers Infinity war that footage is
shown in Universe in the TVA could Kevin
the robot with film reels on his back
and his ability to instantly prune
history like Todd's Hulk blood storyline
could he be another one of the robots
invented by our hunky smoke show Kang
the Conqueror
interesting I think that this robot is
above King I think that this robot is
like it's too it knows too much it has
too much control over the MCU because
like this this robot is literally
writing all of MCU reality like even
Kank story even Kank Stories being
written by this robot so I don't know if
um at this level that it it can be Kang
because um it's just like this is like
it's supposed to be like our reality
like sort of like our universe but like
I obviously not really
um but like yeah I don't think it can be
king
writing his own story but that would be
really fun it'd be really I like that
idea a lot but I don't know it's a
really fun idea I think it's a fun idea
but it's like what came first the
chicken or the egg and so it's like even
if Kang made this spot that creates all
of the Marvel properties it's like
someone created him that created the
Marvel bot and so that's why I'm like I
think it is easier to track for them and
for us probably the fact that like
Jessica GAO created this robot and I'm
not saying like she's all above us like
Kevin feige is but it's like she created
the bot because at the end of the day
the writers in that room could just do
like an uproar strike and just tear that
robot apart uh if it's stuck to a wall
and if they could get into it as easy as
She-Hulk did it's like okay it seems
like we could still take apart this
robot if somehow Disney got rid of
Marvel Studios for some reason that
robot would also go away so it's like I
feel like Kang could stop that if it if
he did create it so that's why I'm like
I think it's just a stupid robot
[Laughter]
with a little hat and an old camera lens
that I mean I love the look of him but
I'm also like uh you guys did not
upgrade this robot and it is 2022. this
robot has literally the 1930s like a
photo like black and white the freaking
uh what is it called uh acid tin type
tin type lenses so it's like this thing
is just old TV
um but I mean I love that he's smart I
love that he's always absorbing every
comic that's ever been made yeah I mean
look Jessica GAO is now MCU Cannon she
exists she was in that writer's room so
and she uh had no control over this
robot in universe that's what I'm saying
in Universe there could be another layer
of meta justification for how this robot
exists and there must be there must be
by definition a robot could not always
exist someone must have built it so was
it just Disney Executives who programmed
it to be able to track stories and be
able to churn out new things like the
manatees and in the in South Park yeah
is that I mean that's probably what it
is right it was a Boston Dynamics making
a new robot
um
yeah
ill Boston
um I think it I think in in Canada
your disrespect take you and your
dunking get out of here
um sorry for those from Boston uh but
yeah it's it's so funny too because
Jessica gal did an interview about the
robot where she was like I came up with
30 endings and this is the one that
Kevin feige chose so it's like it's like
what are you gonna what are you gonna do
with this robot I I feel like you can
touch on it again in the future but well
that's what I'm saying if it's the one
Kevin feige chose he's like well I
already have my big bad who loves to
build robots to do his bidding in a in a
Godly timeline erasing and creating
world like think did were you guys not
reminded by the robot that stripped down
Loki naked at the beginning with a weird
little face and the weird arms like I
feel like this guy likes to build his
little gizmos I think there's a very
easy tether to draw there I don't know
if it ever will I just like the theory
this really reminds me of Wally and it
literally is the same introduction as
the Droid and Wally that disobeys every
command that it's watching everybody on
a screen and then it's like no
no so I also was like is Kevin feige
trying to
like show himself as an evil person
um and there's nobody he's evil though
well that's the thing there's no okay
first off I don't think he's evil either
but there has never been show me a scene
and a TV show where the robot that
ascends from the roof is a good
character and says only good things
because I'm like robot house it was bad
and uh even smart a smart house I said
Roblox robot house Smart House you know
uh
what about uh Rosie and The Jetsons did
Rosie live in the Attic or did she
ascend from the floor I think she came
from from the floor they're good from
the attic from up above it's problematic
I don't know if you guys ever played the
portal series of games but um that
worked out just fine uh oh okay good to
know robot good to know totally totally
above board they're good people robots
oh I'm just kidding no it was terrible
terrible experience I mean maybe it's
just me I'm um I'm squirreled away alone
in this uh blue room and I felt sympathy
for this devil who's chained away in his
room with his comic books just trying to
make the best story lines using his
robot brain uh I I get it I get where
he's coming from and he can't really
please everyone I I can't help but root
for this this weird little um
he makes more money than all of us and
he's a robot he doesn't have to eat he
doesn't have children
his money is made up capital is a myth
and it doesn't exist it's just opening
it up
each other so we don't have a revolution
against the power oh if only Disney
believe this if only Disney believed it
but I get where you're coming from as a
human that has the same kind of
situations that happen but don't feel
bad for this robot this robot is fine
I love that robot I love his little hat
I love the hat the most the Hat makes it
do they better make a Kevin hat like
that they better make the Kevin hat like
once it showed I was like oh why isn't
Kevin [ __ ] wearing that right now I
was like where is he at I cannot wait to
see the cosplays of uh of Kevin the
robot that's gonna look so great yeah
what will he it will be someone on a
fishing pole wearing like a green screen
suit or something like that carrying
this thing around I want I want to build
one in my room like I'm gonna like turn
my whole identity into Kevin no I you
know people are gonna come out of this
week being like again Voss worships at
the altar of Kevin feige maybe I do I
mean we all love Kevin foggy here we all
like we owe so much to give a buggy
because he has ushered in an Era of Good
superhero movies like before the MCU we
were getting [ __ ] man so like this is
all hail the Kevin robot in my opinion
I'll handle the camera robot we have
some more questions we need to get
through from this episode first let's
thank the people who sponsored us the
second season of the hit show DC's
Batman the audio Adventures is now out
on HBO Max Gotham City a seating
cauldron of crime and Corruption about
to boil over in a long shadow of
two-faced and the Penguins combined
criminal might Gotham City is gripped in
Twin fists of passion and Terror as
harleen quinzel bulldozes a path to her
heart's desire and scarecrow floods the
city with new and improved nightmares
tune in for a tale of life and death in
Gotham City starring Jeffrey Wright
Rosario Dawson Bradley Whitford Jillian
Jacobs Keenan Thompson and Chris Parnell
friend of the channel Bobby Moynihan
plays the penguin Bobby I know if you're
watching but we love you and we'd love
to host you in anything you want to
appear on camera because you're amazing
and we know how much you love toys we'll
just do a whole episode about toys if
you want when Bobby said an interview
with TV Insider that it's the role he is
most proud of in his career can you
believe that I can't wait to listen
stream DC's Batman the audio Adventures
season 2 now on HBO Max we also want to
think Helix sleep for sponsoring this
episode of sleep is important and here
at new rockstars We Trust Helix to
protect our sleep with the best
mattresses in the world I have a helix
mattress as does MT and recently
producer Zach and producer John also got
a helix mattress Helix sleep has a quiz
that just takes two minutes to complete
and matches your body type and your
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you everybody's unique and
Helix knows that so they have several
different mattress models to choose from
they have soft medium and firm
mattresses mattress is great for cooling
you down if you sleep hot mattress is
great for spinal alignment to prevent
morning aches and pains and even a helix
plus mattress for plus size sleepers
producer John take the Helix quiz was
matched to the Helix dusk mattress
because he's a back sleeper that needed
a memory foam mattress to provide the
perfect amount of support to keep him
sleeping through the night just go to
helixsleep.com inside marble take their
two minute sleep quiz and they will
match you to a customized mattress that
will give you the best sleep of your
life they have a 10 year warranty and
you get to try it out for 100 nights
risk free Helix is offering up to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com inside marble and thank
you to roon for sponsoring this episode
much like Jennifer Walters we all want
to have clothes that we look good in and
feel confident wearing even if we don't
need to Hulk out the dress shirt was due
for a radical reinvention in Ruins
stepped into the challenge rhone's
commuter shirt is the most comfortable
breathable and flexible shirt known to
man ruins comfortable four-way stretch
fabric provides breathability and
flexibility that leaves you free to
enjoy what life throws your way from
your work time to your free time with
rhone's wrinkle free release technology
wrinkles disappear as you stretch and
wear the T-shirt that's it's just so
easy Roan is 100 machine washable so you
can ditch the dry cleaner all together
producer Zach loves his commuter shirt
because he can go from work straight to
dinner with the in-laws feeling fresh
and looking its best the commuter sure
can get you through any work day and
straight into whatever comes next head
to rhone.com Marvel and use the promo
code Marvel to save 20 off your entire
order that's 20 off your entire order
when you head to
rhone.com Marvel and use a code Marvel
it's time to find your quarter office
Comfort let's dig more into this uh
ending scene will Hulk and Scar and
She-Hulk team up in a world war Hulk
title and uh generally what do we feel
about descending
um I I I was I made that noise because I
was coughing I was coughing
um I laugh at the worst times and I
cough at the worst times I found that
out yesterday so I want the thing is I
think I already made my argument where I
was like I want as a post credit scene
only because like it's such a big thing
and all we can make of what's gonna
happen in the future with scar is what
we saw in that scene which is him
standing behind his dad looking upset
with an okay haircut so
trying
it's it's interesting it's I say okay
because it's not bad we've all been
teens and cut our hair in a weird way
the best Jess I don't know but hey it's
fine not to roast a small green boy but
my goodness that did not look great
small green boy I'm not too worried the
haircut's ridiculous but I just I want
more answers on what exactly happened on
sakar what was going on there was scar
causing trouble uh what is he like a
fugitive from sakar is was he a champion
in the fighting arena like what were the
reasons why he left I just give this kid
at least one line to give us a sense is
he like a Bart Simpson little jerk uh is
he like a shy kid yes okay so from that
scene of him standing behind his dad
like
like this he was like I do think he got
like in trouble and he I think either I
think there's there's two ways we can go
about this because I don't know if we'll
follow the world war Hulk storyline
completely because that means we'll
probably we'd have to get like a really
mean Reckless Hulk again so I think it's
a matter of like either the mom is like
you need to come get your son you need
to take him for a weekend you need to
like do something because he is like 60
years old it's a car time like I need
you to come put some work in and so it
could be that or it could be that she
passed away and I think it's the first
one I think she's like this is your son
come here and get it which I at first
was like I don't think Hulk would do all
that but it's also like maybe Hulk did
do that maybe he just didn't remember
when he turned back into smart Hulk that
he had sex with someone and had an
offspring and he just left and there
it's probably really hard to get in
contact with him on Earth that's why
they had to send the sakarian Courier
craft so it's like and then find him
once they got there so it's like yeah I
could see this just being like a um a
like um was it called I had it when
you're a single mom and not child
support but but something along those
lines
because
joint custody yeah kind of like I
don't know my mom is definitely where
she was like okay uh Jessica's a handle
like a lot it's your time to take like
accountability and take care of her for
some time so I think it might be that
see like I'm I'm really interested to
see because like you know I really do
think that this is a situation where
um you know Hulk the Hulk Persona not
Bruce had sex with a woman on sakar and
Bruce had no idea like Bruce had no idea
that he had a son and uh maybe Hulk had
an idea but like Hulk was just like you
know what whatever I I get laid and it
it's what happens
um but like I think that um what's gonna
be really interesting moving forward is
that like you know we see Bruce himself
introducing scar as his son but like how
does Hulk feel about this like does
hulkit is saying like how he raises the
person that you know like that his truth
like that's the whole son that's not
really Bruce's son it is Bruce's son
biologically but like the Hulk probably
wants to be a father and so like maybe
that could be Catalyst for what we're
all I mean like probably not I low-key
think he dipped out also because of this
reason not dipped out but you know like
he kind of it was easier to sequester
him because he was like I don't know
because like we do know from uh Thor
Ragnarok that like Hulk just you know he
he does want to be accepted to some
degree like he doesn't like that the
Earth doesn't like him and like you know
he he likes being alone because like he
doesn't really have someone to Vibe with
and so like if he had a son that was
just like him I feel like Hulk would be
sort of hyped to be like yo like I don't
have to be alone and like I can smash
with you know like my son and like we
could smash stuff together
I mean like not smash yourself
let's not get incest a year hey you keep
your smash into yourself
yeah no no I just think it's um I don't
know very interesting yeah I think uh
whatever the storyline will be I suspect
it'll be on earth I like the idea of
like a World War Hulk kind of story and
I think that we're just going to explore
more hulks I think especially if they're
gonna put a movie's budget behind it and
that would be my expectation of where it
is uh I'm excited I don't need to see
scars show up we don't need to wait for
another Hulk movie though like pop that
kid into whatever anything else
everyone's having children and we still
haven't really seen because it's like I
mean okay arguably I don't know if Wanda
has children I don't know if I want to
count that but like Thor love and
thunder we know that he now kind of has
a daughter and so it and I mean she's
really young and if we want to count
like kind of K Bishop it's not like a
daughter but daughter figure it's like
it's I guess it depends on like how we
want to see him the scar want to like
because there's a lot of this beef about
Young Avengers and all this stuff but
like are we trying to go that route and
incorporate him or are we just gonna go
first to the Hulk movie I feel like it's
gonna be expensive the Hulk movie so
it'll be a minute oh yeah yeah super
pricey you know what I hope Marvel is
doing are some uh screen tests and
chemistry tests
um between these kids because all these
kids are being cast based off of the
relationship with the adult actors in
the movie I mean they cast Chris
Hemsworth's daughter yes yes I mean yeah
like oh these two boys were cast for
their connection with Elizabeth Olsen
and by the way they're great I'm sure
all these kids can connect with each
other in different ways I'm just saying
like when you watch stranger things how
important is it that all those kids get
along together you know like they they
seem like they're actual you can relax
you can sense it on Stranger Things I
don't care what anyone says you can feel
it when it's like they don't really like
each other they don't really like each
other right and like and you feel that
in Euphoria as well those are younger
actors most of them are like adults
technically but like it's with
Spider-Man uh homecoming they were kids
they were all like 15 16 when they got
cast and how important was it that they
all got along the Harry Potter films
those three kids like grew up together
and you you feel that like that
chemistry is so important I maybe the
reason they're holding up on the Young
Avengers is like they're still trying to
figure out the exact chemistry that is
essential when you're watching The
Coming of Age youth group dynamic is
they all have to like they have to be
fun when they interact with each other
they can't just be kids who are cast
separately by different you know cast or
be probably the same kind casting
director across several different titles
but the way these kids have been
introduced in these titles don't seem
like they have friends they seem like
they just have some weird kind of
connection with an Avenger that's and
that's my kind of fear with hiring Chris
Hemsworth's daughter because it was like
I get it she's really cute and it is
your biological daughter but also like
her with Kate Bishop is gonna be weird
okay Bishop is Haley Steinfeld a great
actress I I honestly feel like in the
love situation we're gonna see like a
huge time Jump like something's gonna
happen because we're in this like weird
timeline gangs type of situation we're
probably gonna get like a like a a super
fast forward for like love for um in
both of Wanda's kids like we're not
gonna see those actors
um much like we saw with um with uh
ant-man's daughter
um like that out was a difference well
they changed obviously yeah I was like
they changed the action I think that's
what they're going to do with love I
think they're gonna just change it yeah
I think that like these kid actors like
were just like hey this is fun to have
like Chris ember's daughter in it but
like she's gonna be that character is
probably gonna age up like dramatically
well also you have the whole side to her
character that she's a cosmic entity
that was like the character of Eternity
transmuted itself into love so and then
the reflection of the water she was like
an outline of like Cosmic innards so
like yes there are there's a way that
you could just like have her like Witch
of Ash's Pokemon just start to go crazy
one time he's like I don't know what's
wrong with it was it metaphor it's like
why is it Metapod talking to me like I
think it's gonna be like that where like
my daughter's going through some weird
puberty stage I don't know what's
happening and it just starts floating in
the sky and glowing like in Naruto or
something like ah what is happening
enter and then you can cast anyone to
play the part because she's a cosmic
entity anything crazy could happen with
her she's gonna stay a little girl
basically like I I don't think that um
Chris Temple's daughter is going to be
playing the role for forever I mean she
did a great job for what she did but
like I don't think that that's the plan
yeah she's fine she was fun uh look
Jessica Mt there's so much we want to
talk about coming out of the series The
episode has gone on too long so I think
what I would what I really want to do is
uh obviously answer more questions
coming out of She-Hulk and this is like
the last Disney plus title of phase four
so I want to do a full like phase four
analysis I want to hear like how does
She Hulk rank up with these other titles
like I I think I need like a few days to
really gestate on that so why don't we
save that conversation for next week uh
and do a whole episode just kind of
looking at phase four these Disney plus
titles
from a from a macro uh bird's eye
perspective I think right now we're
still kind of uh
digesting what we just saw in the finale
of She-Hulk I think it would we'd
benefit from some days to um to think
about now so uh in the meantime I think
this is a fun place to to end this
finale of She-Hulk and to end phase four
the revealing that this crazy robot is
making all these creative decisions is
such an insane big swing and I'm feeling
good about the MCU right now and part of
the reason I feel so good about it is I
get to talk about it every week with uh
you Jessica and umt it's been such a
delight uh and Jess uh everything you
have done with the breakdowns uh from
episode one to now your work has been so
so good and I know you had a very very
difficult job taking on this I mean to
to come in and be the person who breaks
down a Marvel Disney Plus show on new
rock stars like yeah there's there's it
hasn't been easy I can't imagine it's
been easy for you but you have knocked
it out of the park you like your D your
analysis has been so on point you have
found stuff that I never would have seen
in a million years so thank you so much
for doing that it's so great I can't
wait to see what you do more for us
thank you
great job
um including letting you get to work on
it now this episode's right yeah I'm so
sorry I'm going to Rogue Theory in 10
minutes
oh my goodness okay well let's get out
of here um that's it for this episode of
inside Marvel
um thank you so much for watching be
sure to subscribe to new rockstars
follow Mt at mastertonment uh follow
Jessica Lulu underscore Clements follow
me at eavos subscribe to inside Marvel
wherever you get your podcasts uh be
sure to watch Jess's Easter egg
breakdown it's coming to the channel
tomorrow thank you all so much for
watching and we'll see you next week
foreign